EU agriculture ministers exchanged views  this month on how to address the lack of  plant protection products for minor  crops like vegetables and fruits and  major crops hit by less common diseases  the products for these so-called minor  uses are not economically sustainable  for the plant protection industry but  they are important for growers according  to the European Commission the direct  impact of losses juda pests or diseases  from these crops in the EU totals more  than 1 billion euros each year the  ministers will discuss a commission  report outlining the obstacles to minor  uses of plant protection products and  its recommendation to set up an  independent coordination facility as the  best way of overcoming the problem the  council will also look at food waste in  Europe and here are some suggestions for  reducing the problem and discuss when EU  rules on the protection of animals  during transport might be revised